في ايه تريل الماضي اثارت لعبه هاجي واجي
الجدل بعدما انتشر تحذير للاباء عبر
الانترنت حول هذه اللعبه الالكترونيه دميه
الشريره تحاول اقناع الصغار
لكن بعد التحقيق اتضح ان لا ادله على
توجيه الاطفال
يملك جسدا ازرق نحيلا له ابتسامه مخيفه فم
مليء بصفوف من الاسنان الحاده اللعبه في
الاساس موجهه لاخافه البالغين لكنها لاقت
رواجا واسعا عند الصغار الشرير الازرق
يثير الجدل من جديد في روسيا والعابه
محظور للبيع في البلاد بعد الكشف عن
احتوائي 89% من الالعاب التي تباع في
المتاجر على ماده الفينال وباكثر من اربعه
اضعاف النسبه المسموحه ما قد يصيب الاطفال
بالصداع والغثيان
الالعاب المحظوره هي من شركات مصنعه غير
معتمده ومنخفضه الجوده لكن على اي حال
تعاهدت الشركات بتصحيح الاخطاء
العاب الاطفال خطيره اكثر مما تتصور
84% من الالعاب البلاستيكيه القديمه تحتوي
على مواد كيماويه سامه يتجاوز بعضها
الحدود القانونيه المسموحه حاليا باربع
مئه مره وفقا لدراسه اجراها باحثون في
جامعه لكن الالعاب الحديثه لم تسلم ايضا
حيث اكتشف الباحثون ان 30% من العينات
تتجاوز الحدود المسموح بها من المواد
الكيماويه وان كانت اقل خطرا من الالعاب
القديمه من حيث التركيب المواد الكيماويه
المحظوره يمكن ان تستغرق سنوات لتتحلل في
الجسم وقد تسبب السرطان او تضر بالحمض
النووي بالحمض النووي حسب الدراسه كما
يمكنها تعطيل النمو القدرات الايجابيه لدى
الاطفال في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احنا شرينا منها كثير هاي اللعبه هاي
السنه بعدها الخبر
بس وكمان على سيرتها اللعبه في كثير لانه
الولايات المتحده مثلا دليل سلامه الالعاب
التجاريه الموجوده في الولايات المتحده
لانه كل الالعاب المعده للاستخدام انه اي
اطفال يستخدم
الالعاب التي يتبعها الكونجرس حلو في
اوروبا مثلا بعد امريكا
خلي مسدسات
مثلا يا نادين هناك نقاش مستوى عالي طويل
حول تقليدها في الولايات المتحده تحديدا
لمنع الاطفال من التطبيعه مع العنف خلال
سنوات الماضيه اين مبادرات في عده الدول
يحطوا فيها الاطفال اسلحتهم كمان وعلى
فكره في لعبه كثير هلا انتشرت مؤخرا هذه
اللعبه لها ثلاثيه اجنحه هيك بيسموها
بتقعد تحربيه الالعاب بسم الله عليك اكيد
كثير
خصوصا بال 2017
منصه يقفزون عليها بشعون بالمرح لكن همم
لا مشكله لكن بادئه من 2012 توصلت
الاكاديميه الامريكيه لطب الاطفال يناديل
ان هذا الجهاز يشكل مخاطر كثيره وعاليه
للحدوث اصابات شديده وضعت ارشادات عامه
ومفصله لاستخدام الترامبولين يعني انا كله
مش مشكله مستغني عنه بس حسيت الا
لترامبولين ترامبو